you're invited to a coming-out party
here in the Okavango Delta in Botswana
Africa three weeks ago these wild
painted dog mothers gave birth to a
perky pile of pups the pucks are ready
to leave the borough and join the pack
until now the mothers hadn't let anyone
near the pups but now the whole pack can
welcome the new arrivals this is when
the social structure shifts into an
extreme matriarchy not only is the
dominant female in charge in general she
now also takes charge of all the pups of
all the mothers in fact the dominant
mother is the only one allowed to nurse
all the pups of all the females who gave
birth in this case that's 21 hungry
mouths this doesn't sit so well with the
other mothers to be shut out this early
and this completely no more nuzzling no
more licking their wounds too huh I
don't think so one of the disgruntled
moms decides to take matters into her
own mouth she kidnapped a pub and
absconds with it she and a cohort carry
it back to another borough of course the
dominant female wouldn't be the dominant
female if she let pack members get away
with shenanigans like this she drives
off these rabble-rousers and then three
kidnaps the errant cop what a woman bold
as an action hero while nursing this and
20 other cops this has got to be your
mother of the year